by now if you're following social media
at all or even the the mainstream media
you know that Facebook recently got
caught in a bit of a public relations
bind when it became public knowledge
that they engaged in a experiment on
some of their users back in 2012 so
there's been a lot of responses about
this some of them very neat jerk some of
them very thoughtful and I want to
reflect a little bit on what it means
for us in what we call the Technosphere
what I want to do in this video because
I'm going to do a follow-up to this
video most likely next week what I want
to do in this one is primarily two
things I want to go over the details of
what actually happened so it's sort of
an informative video and then I want to
talk about some of the most common
positive and negative responses on the
part of people who've been talking about
this or expressing opinions about this
and then I'm going to finish up just by
hitting on a few points that I'll talk
about in the next video I'm not going to
explore here but i do want to to bring
to white so let's actually start out
with you know the raw information that
we have what actually took place so
Facebook carried out a study and it was
led by this guy Adam Kramer was a lead
researcher on the study it ran for one
week in January 2012 and it had to do
with 680 9003 facebook users who were
the effect at once now just to put
things in proportion facebook at this
time has roughly around a billion users
they estimate so this would be less than
1% of facebook users in any case what
they did is they they change the
algorithms that they were using if you
you know if you don't know this this is
a little bit of background information
Facebook a long time ago quit just
displaying whatever happened to come up
and they started using algorithms to
determine what posts you're probably
going to be most interested in and what
they were most interested in showing you
and they change these algorithms up
every so often in any case what are they
designed to do they're designed to bring
some content to the top and and put some
content below or if you're you know
clicking on that the top posts you only
get a very small filtered amount of the
the raw material that that's coming your
way so what did they do they removed all
or some of the positive posts in some
people's feed for that week coming from
their their Facebook friends and in
other ppls they did exactly the opposite
they removed all or some of the negative
posts and what they wanted to do was see
whether this would affect how other
people were posting the people who are
being being subjected to the experiment
they wanted to see specifically whether
getting a higher proportion a negative
post would would lead them to post more
negative comments negative posts and
conversely whether more positive posts
would lead to people doing more positive
posting and what they found is there was
a you know there was a significant
correlation that when they change the
algorithm it produced an average of one
positive or negative post / or negative
or positive word out of 1,000 words for
the people that were in this experiment
so you know translated into less numeric
language what this means is that if you
were getting subjected to this filtering
and it was skewing towards the negative
your posts your comments on your friends
feeds on your own wall would be slightly
more negative you
use a little bit more negative language
and likewise if you were getting you
know higher dose of positive stuff then
you would use slightly more positive
words in your own feeds but again
increase on average of one in a thousand
so if you think about just how much you
actually post on Facebook you know if
you're writing five sentences a day you
might only be doing 100 words in those
those sentences if you're you know one
of these Facebook people who writes you
know page after page after page of stuff
of course you can go through a thousand
words fairly quickly so the study was
then developed into an article which was
called experimental evidence of massive
scale emotional contagion through social
networks and I've got a link to it here
for you in the description that's a
rather ambitious wording for this
experimental evidence of massive scale
emotional contagion through social
networks and we can talk a little bit
more about that in the next video about
why this is you know kind of
over-the-top language there anyway it
was published in the Proceedings of the
National Academy of Sciences of the USA
in 2012 and there were two other
researchers in on it Jamie guillory I
think that so his name is pronounced and
Jeffrey Hancock both of whom are from
Cornell now the the study was used by
some other researchers and was being
cited in literature but it was more or
less under the radar unless you were
into that sort of thing I have to admit
I didn't know about it myself until the
story broke and then New Scientist
brings it to light and says hey look at
what's going on and that it just blew up
it turned into a major story and people
start weighing in on all different sides
Adam Kramer actually defended his
research on facebook interestingly
enough and said you know they
along the lines of well you know we
didn't really mean to upset anybody but
you can read his own stuff I'll link to
that here as well Facebook's coo sheryl
sandberg apologized for the interview
mishandling of it Susan Fisk the editor
of the article in the journal said that
the study was actually IRB approved and
we'll talk about what that means in a
moment as it turns out it doesn't look
like it actually was the journal itself
defended the publication of the study
and the latest bit of interesting stuff
is that some European countries are
looking at this and seeing whether
there's any privacy concerns that have
been violated because they tend to you
know somewhat stricter laws some of
those some of those countries and the
Electronic Privacy Information Center or
epic has just asked the FTC to do an
investigation and they filed a complaint
so that's what has taken place there's
one other thing that I should specify as
well which is that this is part of you
know a big data approach to research
with respect to language which wants to
identify emotions that people are having
on the basis of their their speech and
it does so by looking for particular
keywords and this is a very coarse way
of looking at emotion they positive or
negative and there's really no parsing
of this to you know determine whether
somebody is using a positive term in an
ironic way so that it's actually
negative or vice versa it's actually
rather crude but I'm going to talk about
you know my misgivings about this
research and this kind of approach in
the next video so now let's talk about
some of the responses because i find
this this you know really interesting
and it raises a lot of important
questions not only about ethics but even
about language and ontology and
epistemology there's there's a lot of
stuff rolled up
here and add about public discourse and
how that should work so here's the first
thing to actually say about about what
happened Facebook was carrying out a
study and they're not the only people
doing this but they got they got caught
with their hand in the jar this one they
were carrying out a study that he had to
do with producing emotional responses or
what we call effect and seeing whether
that could lead to changed behavior in
this case the change behavior was
actually linguistic behavior it was
posting so they're seeing whether one
kind of action positive or negative
language uses can lead to an increase in
positive or negative language uses with
the the person in the middle the one
who's being experimented upon you know
their emotions being involved and as it
turns out this study doesn't really
demonstrate that much because it wasn't
a huge increase you know went on for a
week it didn't have a great effect on
the people who are posting positive or
negative but they did manage to produce
an emotional response because a lot of
people are very ticked off and now
notice too it's not just that they have
a negative response it's an anger
response so ironically Facebook managed
to produce a much more consistent
response than than they had intended to
buy the experiment and I would actually
be surprised if there isn't somebody to
sort of out there doing data analysis on
these responses to see you know what
could be made of those so that's the
first thing I wanted to say now I'm
going to talk about the the people who
are criticizing Facebook's actions and
then I'll talk about some of the
defenses that are made and then I'll
wrap up by
on some of the things that I I'm
particularly interested in so I
mentioned this term IRB IRB stands for
institutional research board and I've
been on an IRB and I've had to submit
for I arbys and what an IRB is is it's a
bunch of people you often see these in
universities it's a bunch of people who
look over proposals that are made that
have to do with human subjects and they
determine whether they can say yes you
can proceed with this experiment or no
and it's supposed to be on ethical
grounds now I myself have a lot of
misgivings about the way I arbys work I
don't think that they actually embody
any sense of ethics and robo robo sense
you know very well when they do work
well I think that's the exception rather
than norm but that's that's a separate
issue in any case what an IRB is
supposed to be doing in theory is it
supposed to be having a lot of people
review the proposal and then say give
you a thumbs-up or a thumbs-down or you
need to revise it and here's the
problems with it and there are certain
key features of experiment design of
study design that are going to be
focused on by any IRB so one of the
important things that comes up is what's
called informed consent and we'll get to
that in a moment but there's other
things as well that have to do with the
human subjects now an IRB is not
actually needed for a private company to
carry out experiments it's needed if
you're a university researcher and
that's because that's a fairly recent
thing that's that's you know in large
part it's been a response to unethical
experiments being carried out in the
past and if you if you want to if you
want to take the course that is offered
by the national institutes of health
that you know sort of walks you through
what you have to do and you know some
places you actually have to
done that course in order to do an IRB
application I know that was a case when
I was at Fayetteville State they'll tell
you about like you know the Tuskegee
Experiment and this experiment and all
this this unethical experimentation and
I arbys came about in order to try to be
kind of a guard rail safeguard against
unethical experimentation taking place
unethical in the sense that it would
violate people's rights or otherwise
harm the human subjects that it's being
conducted on now what is required by the
IRB in most areas we would call this
disclosure in in the IRB setting it's
called informed consent and so the idea
is that people who are involved in
experimentation need to actually know
that they're part of an experiment now
they don't necessarily need to know that
they're being experimented on in this
way or this way or this way or this way
as a matter of fact some experiments are
set up so that somebody thinks they're
being tested for this but they're
actually being tested for something else
but they do need to know that they're
part of an experiment they do need to
know you know certain parameters of it
Facebook didn't reveal that to anybody
who was involved so a lot of people are
angry because Facebook essentially
experimented on its users without
letting them know that that was going to
be the case and one of the things that
is an option for for somebody if they
know they're being experimented on to
say I don't want to be part of the
experiment so without any sort of
disclosure it's not possible to opt out
of the experiment again so some people
are criticizing Facebook for that reason
another thing that people are quite
angry about is that Facebook was
essentially trying to manipulate its
users and their use of the product of
the platform to produce in them and
emotional response which then would lead
to some sort of action or
behavior in this case a change in their
language that's what the study was
intended to look at and that's what they
they experimented on so there's there's
two parts there that people don't like
they don't like people messing around
with their emotions and they also don't
like people making them do things yeah
you know and you can raise a lot of
questions at this point did Facebook
actually make anybody do anything in any
strict sense of those terms it seems
pretty hard to make a case for that even
you know if you look at extreme cases
because they're you know the average was
one in a thousand words so maybe there
was somebody who you know wrote a
hundred negative terms on average out of
a thousand so one out of every ten of
their words became pejorative there you
know that be an outlier but maybe that
that actually did happen people don't
like the sense that they're being
manipulated and its really interesting
here because because you know if you're
a Facebook user odds are you were not
one of the people who was manipulated
but it seems like a lot of people have
taken on the idea that they were indeed
manipulated by Facebook during this
experiment so there's there's that
that's that's another criticism that's
being made a third criticism that you
can make is that this experiment
involved a kind of censorship of
information this actually strikes me as
a really good criticism facebook already
has algorithms in place that as one of
the the bloggers who's commenting on
this said you know they keep you from
seeing the posts of people who are not
easy to get a handle on in Facebook's
algorithms or who don't contribute much
to Facebook your posts go further down
and you could see that as a kind of
censorship I think the censorship is a
little bit strong there because
censorship implies you know things being
taken out so even in normal Facebook
some people's posts are rising up higher
some people's posts are going going in a
deeper into the depths where they're
probably not going to be seen just like
with Google listings that's happening
all the time you know there's an awful
lot of money spent on trying to boost
things now Facebook was not just doing
their normal algorithms in this case
they were actually changing the
algorithms so that positive posts were
being taken out for those who are being
tested for negative response and
negative posts were being taken out for
those who are testing for positive
response and it's interesting the
complaints that are being made have to
do mainly with is Facebook depressing
people because it doesn't seem like
anybody's saying yeah you know Facebook
was making people happy happier than
they ought to have been but really what
was happening in that case is if I was
writing negative posts and you're my
facebook friend my negative posts were
being filtered out so that they can see
whether that would make you happier
which means they're actually censoring
me which means that they're actually
censoring the information coming to you
so I think that that's a valid complaint
that's being made there's some
investigations going on right now about
whether this violated privacy
expectations rights mostly that's
happening in Europe I don't really know
enough about that to say very much at
this point I don't see myself this
having to do so much with privacy as
with things like informed consent
manipulation and censorship another big
complaint that's been made and this
one's kind of an interesting one is that
this research is tied to military
research into producing emotional
reactions a fact military oriented or
funded research through this this agency
Minerva which is interested in questions
like could we replicate the
Arab Spring we remember Twitter played a
huge role in in that you know does
emotional contagion work through social
networks if it does can we use it to you
know suppress the movements that we
don't want and boost the movements that
we we do want and you know the military
has been interested in this sort of
thing for a long time we're not the only
ones that are interested in this the
Chinese military is very interested in
this sort of thing there's there's all
sorts of other players involved but in
this case the concern is that Facebook
the Facebook researcher is colluding
with you know people who are connected
with the military notice it's not the
Facebook researcher himself directly but
one of the other article writers who is
who's being targeted namely Hancock so
those are the big negative responses to
this and let's look now at some of the
responses that aren't so much positive
responses but more like damage control
hey this isn't that big of a deal sort
of sort of arguments and the first one
that I think is particularly bad its
Facebook you know has had a few people
saying oh you know we didn't mean to
upset anybody that strikes me as
complete BS because obviously they meant
to upset people even the experiment
themselves because that was the whole
purpose of the experiment at least half
of the experiment to see whether by
introducing a higher proportion of
negative or negatively worded posts they
could get you to make more negative
responses they could make it you know
the flip side and say well you know we
also for every person who had negative
responses and who you know came away
from Facebook a little bit grouchy or
depressed or whatever there were also a
whole bunch of people who for everyone
that that happened to there's at least
another one who got an unduly positive
spin on things
you know came out of the the experiment
with greater buoyancy or pick whatever
you want but I think all of this is
really just you know spin and nobody
should believe any of that the you know
the lead researcher knew exactly what he
was doing this is not somebody just you
know accidentally bumping into you on
the street this is a massive experiment
that was carried out they knew exactly
what they were getting into so that
strikes me as just you know self-serving
yes other people are making the argument
and this is an argument that gets made a
lot in technology circles this serves
the greater good and the buzzword with
that is innovation innovation requires
that we let researchers you know try out
different things experiment and you know
if you tell people that you're
experimenting on them you're not going
to get good data and you know so we you
know we we values Science &
experimentation and all that so that's a
good thing man maybe so but then you
know the argument has to go beyond just
science science science we're not even
really sure if this is science anyway I
mean doing statistical analyses doesn't
buy itself turn it into science or good
science but in any case the idea is that
this innovation is going to make our
lives better that's the utilitarian
argument for this that if we let
Facebook experiment on a small bunch of
people whose rights are being violated
in some you know small ways but not not
really big ways it's not like anyone
ninos really getting that harm by this
then it's going to make for much better
user experience for all the rest of us
and Facebook is this you know by doing
this really serving the greater good of
everybody I don't really find that
argument all that plausible in part not
so much because I actually disagree with
how it's it's set up or you know because
I have a big beef with utilitarianism as
such it's more that in my view
there's there's too easy of a an appeal
to innovation innovation is a buzz word
unless you can actually show me what
innovation came from it this is actually
being a good utilitarian unless you can
actually show me what innovation came
from it or is likely to come from it
your argument doesn't stand and don't
point me at past things and NASA and you
know you know plastics and velcro and
paying because that's not Facebook
that's that's a whole different thing
you know NASA gets to make their
arguments about their stuff Facebook's
got to make their own arguments about
their product and and what innovations
are coming from it and how it's
improving all of our lives and you know
they probably could i'd actually be
happy to give them pointers on it but i
doubt that's going to happen another
argument that that's getting made is
what this is a pretty small study it
really didn't affect that many people
and you know though the ones that were
actually negatively affected by it who
might have gotten you know a little bit
depressed or angry or pick whatever
negative emotions you want anxious
jealous you know all these negative
effects it's only a very small
percentage of the the users so really
this isn't that big of a deal and in one
respect their right because if there's a
billion users and you're experimenting
on say seven hundred thousand of them
that's a very small proportion on the
other hand an absolute number seven
hundred thousand strikes me as a lot of
people so I don't really buy that one
myself um there's another argument
that's being made which i think is in
some respects a good argument in the
sense that it's an argument that you can
make and technically it's right on the
other hand I think that the people who
make those kinds of arguments display
their their bad character and the fact
that we shouldn't trust them at all by
making that very argument here's the
argument oh look Facebook is a private
corporation they don't actually need
need IRB approval to do anything like
this they certainly didn't need
Cornell's IRB approval and you know the
Cornell researchers they didn't
technically need IRB approval for this
because they weren't the ones actually
gathering the data they were just taking
the information and then you know
helping to parse it that's okay so
technically all that is true there's
there's ways of taking true statements
and making something that's globally
false and what's globally false about
this is there really does need to be
some sort of oversight that's ethics
based that involves competent you know
people looking over this stuff and
saying yeah okay that that's fine or no
no this this you need to actually
disclosed to these people that they're
being experimented on so I don't I don't
buy that one either I certainly don't
buy the the little dodge of you know we
were only parsing the data I remember
you know I'm a philosopher so you
wouldn't think I'd have to do very much
with IRB with human subjects I applied
for I rvs just because i was using
assessment data that had been generated
through having students take you know
the CLA the collegiate learning
assessment in a faculty developed one in
fact degraded one and i wanted to use
that to write an article i had to do an
IRB for that even though all I was doing
was taking somebody else's data and then
parsing it you know why because FSU
wanted to make sure that we cross our
T's and dotted our eyes they wanted to
make sure that we jump through these you
know admittedly kappa pain-in-the-ass
hoops so that we could say yes we
actually do have IRB approval some
people actually look this over and it's
all on on the up and up Cornell you
think would be a little bit better about
that another argument that's being made
and this is closely related as well you
know Facebook technically already has
approval
anybody who's entering into it has as
you know this thing that they have to
click I agree and in it it says that
look your dad might be used for for this
or that there's some problems because
the exact formulation wasn't there in
2012 and it's also kind of a Dodge they
basically have to say look tacit Lee you
agreed to be part of this experiment and
I I don't know I I have a hard time
thinking that really answers people's
objections here's the one that I think
it actually is on track of all the
that's not that big of a deal look when
you sign up for social network and you
participate in it you're part of an
experiment from the beginning you're
next you're involved in an experiment
where people are giving you positive and
negative stuff all the time and you can
you know individuals engage in this sort
of trying to sway people's emotions and
opinions and produce results
corporations do it all the time that's
what we call advertising why is what
Facebook did so beyond the pale that's
the the big objection there and I
actually think the debts on track you
know there's two slogans that that you
might want to use in this case one is
marshall mcluhan the medium is the
message look when you're due in facebook
you're doing something that is different
than other forms of communication you
are participating in a social network do
you have the same expectations that you
would with other things I'm not even
sure I mean it's not like you can say
you know then the newspaper is is
responsible for getting me down because
they're on their editorial pages they're
always negative you know or think about
TV if you live in a major metropolitan
area and you watch the nightly news
you're going to see a lot of killings
and fires and stand
accidents and that might depress you the
medium does matter and then you know
they also say content is king and this
was really about content was what they
were doing so like I said beyond the
pale that we should all now get getting
you know upset and say I'm going to get
off of facebook or Facebook needs to get
its act together I don't know if we want
to say that sort of thing then we should
be as leery of regular facebook as we
are a manipulated facebook because in a
certain sense it's all manipulated so
those are the back and forth you know I
don't want to say pros and cons it's
more like the cons and the well that's
not that bad of a con side and what I
want to bring up as I bring this to a
close is just a few things these these
strike me as the really significant
bigger issues that require more
explanation and exploration than I can
do in this short video and i'm going to
do that my next philosophique
reflections so I brought one of these up
already why are we so bothered by this
case and not so bothered by other
aspects of facebook why is it that a
researcher carrying out a pretty limited
experiment that didn't have huge effects
it certainly did not produce emotional
contagion you know in any sort of
meaningful sense sure there's
statistically meaningful but not
meaningful olin like that wow this could
actually be used unlike bring the Empire
down why are we so bothered by this
that's something I think we really ought
to explore more and think about that if
we're so bothered by this why aren't we
up in arms about the advertising that
takes place every day why do we you know
allow universities to spin all sorts of
stuff including the statistics they have
about say crimes on campus you know
these are these are worth thinking about
the other thing that I think is really
really important to reflect on is there
are some proposals that that Facebook
and maybe you know Google and and other
you know similar companies ought to have
if not something like an institutional
review board they ought to have an
ethics board and so there's a lot of
questions that come up with that you
know I'll just hit on a few of them that
occurred to me as soon as I started
reading about this who's going to be on
that board how are you going to keep
that board from a actually getting
corrupted or blog down how is this not
going to contribute to a culture of
rubber stamping you know is this going
to be transparent and open to people on
the outside you know there's a lot of
concerns there I think that's something
that's well worth exploring though so
I'm going to talk about that another one
another issue that that's come up before
and I think this actually points us
towards is how should we understand
social media companies particularly the
really big ones the ones that not only
do something with their platform like
Twitter does but or LinkedIn does but
have what we would call global or
totalizing ambitions like Facebook does
remember you know just a few years back
Facebook tried to bring out a linkedin
killer why because facebook is something
very different than linkedin facebook is
a company like Apple like Microsoft like
Google like yahoo wanted to be and still
is trying to be where they don't just do
one thing they want to bring everything
under their umbrella so if that's the
case maybe we should consider things
like Google or Facebook to be public
utilities and if that's the case then
what do we do with utilities we have
Public Regulation for them governmental
regulation and oversight so that's
something that's you know were thinking
about as well i'm actually not for
viewing them as utilities i think we
need to see them as something kind of
hybrid and then the other
thing that I want to reflect on is one
of the ideas governing this kind of
experimentation not ideas about is it
ethical or not but more core assumptions
having to do with with the study design
itself how do you actually know what
counts when you're looking at language
as a positive or negative term without
making all sorts of reductive
assumptions and if you're doing that if
you're treating language as something
less like language that is used by human
subjects in communication with each
other and more like a computer code are
you actually you might say falsifying
new research as you're doing your
research are you messing things up in a
certain way and then concealing the fact
that you're doing that I have some
severe misgivings about the claims that
get made in this kind of research I
think it's fascinating stuff as a matter
of fact I you know I'm very interested
in the emotions myself how they're
provoked how their father their you know
manipulated how they're moved in certain
directions what sort of insights we can
have about that but I think that this
research is actually quite crude when it
comes to understanding and
conceptualizing emotion so that's so
that's an issue that I'm going to
explore as well so hopefully you come
away from this with a few thoughts of
your own if you have some go ahead and
share them in the comments and there's
really not much more to say about this
until I do my next video